in the year 2800 two astronauts from
Earth Adam and Jake are seen in their
spaceship they are flying to a planet
named Antares which is rumored to have a
large settlement of humans it turns out
that a deadly virus has left women back
on Earth completely Barren so the two
astronauts are the only hope left for
Humanity their mission is to venture to
Antares find some women and convince
them to travel to earth for the boys
shortly after when the spaceship nears
Antares it suddenly becomes unstable due
to the strange gravitational pull there
Adam and Jake try their best to regain
control of the ship and to some extent
they do but it still ends up crashing on
the surface both the astronauts
sustained minor injuries but Jake comes
off the worst of it Adam quickly escorts
him out before the smoke inside
suffocates them then we are shown an
aerial shot of the planet Antares it is
a Barren Wasteland that has large
formations of rocks everywhere with no
signs of vegetation meanwhile Adam
operates on Jake's wounds and injects
him with a futuristic syringe that heals
him automatically as the two are
conversing suddenly a dog's barking is
heard up until now they had believed
that life on the planet was just a rumor
but with the bark they get renewed
motivation and Adam starts following the
sound after a bit of wandering around he
comes across a primitive looking boy
clutching his dog with a worried luck
Adam tries to get near him but the
scared boy says the snake heads are near
and runs away unfortunately just after a
few minutes he is captured by the
snakeheads who appear to actually be
women clad in primitive military
costumes they quickly knock the little
boy out and take him into custody while
his dog runs away on the other hand Adam
is inspecting the strange place when a
massive earthquake rocks him scared he
immediately calls Jake via his high-tech
watch and asks him to take a geoscan of
the area following this Adam Ventures
further deep into the land until he
comes across a large Temple he covertly
sneaks inside and is taken aback to
witness a large number of women there it
turns out that on this planet women rule
everything while men are forced to
become slaves and a few of them are used
to to procreate inside the temple the
women appear to be chanting some prayers
for their serpent Lord here we get to
know that the religious women belong to
a cult which is led by The Fearless
taxan right then the serpent Lord also
appears from the ground which is a
gigantic Cobra we are then introduced to
the queen of Planet Antares sumuru who
seems to be less than impressed by the
cult's work meanwhile the little boy
from earlier is brought to the room as
Adam watches with shock and horror
taksan reveals that the boy is about to
be sacrificed to the serpent Lord
hearing this the boy's sister Dove who
happens to be one of the Queen's
soldiers starts fighting with taxon's
cult members here it is revealed that
the women inside the temple are divided
into two factions one that works for
taksan and the other that follows the
queen as everyone watches on Dove
continues fighting alone and suddenly
the serpent Lord swoops down and gobbles
up one of the cult members an enraged
taxon orders her women to capture Dove
but the queen stops them claiming it was
just self-defense the two leaders almost
get into an argument of their own but
just then Adam who has been hiding in a
corner gets a call from his friend which
alerts everyone in the room taxon
immediately orders her soldiers to go
after him but Adam uses one of his
high-end guns to create a diversion and
flee during the chaos the little boy
will also manages to escape from the
temple after a while Adam and the little
boy catch up and head to the spaceship
to escape this planet however before
Adam can enter he is shot in the leg by
one of taxan's women still with the help
of Jake and the boy he manages to get
inside the spaceship but the arrow
appears to be poisoned causing him to
slowly lose Consciousness outside the
queen arrives with her own Army and
tells taxan's cult gang to go away at
first they refuse to comply claiming
that it is perfectly legal for women to
kill men but when sumeru asserts that
she is the queen and that she has
jurisdiction over everything they
reluctantly leave following this the
queen enters the spaceship and confronts
the aliens she then takes out an
Anti-Venom and injects it in Adam hence
saving his life in the next scene Adam
and Jake are brought to the Queen's
residence where they managed to meet up
privately Jake reveals that according to
the geoscans he conducted earlier he
found out that the planet is dying and
that is why the earthquakes are so
frequent at Max the planet has two
months before It ultimately
self-destruct later Adam is taken to the
Queen's chamber for interrogation he
introduces himself and mentions that he
is from planet Earth he also claims that
the people on Antares are descendants
from Earth as some people were sent on a
terraforming Mission a thousand years
back they regularly reported their
findings for the first 100 years but
after that all Communications ceased the
Earth also went through a deadly war and
that is why they didn't try to find out
much about their people on Antares
hearing all of this the queen is taken
aback but she nonetheless supports the
claims as their Legend mentions of a
planet called Earth as the two continue
talking the topic of the snake cult
comes up Queen sumeru reveals that due
to the continuous earthquakes the people
reverted to religion and that is when
taxan Rose to power she comes from an
extremely Noble family and believed that
she was destined to become the queen
however the people didn't elect her this
is why she has been Gathering cult
followers so that one day she can take
the throne for herself as for the large
Cobra it just appeared out of nowhere
shocked by the revelations Adam tries to
explain that the planet is dying and
that everyone should immediately
evacuate but the queen doesn't want to
listen to a man instead she starts
talking about why men are dominated on
Antares she reveals that long long ago
the men ignited a large flash of Light
which killed a lot of people from that
day onwards the women have taken control
over the land and it is perfectly legal
to kill men if they are found to be
disobedient shortly after the queen
leads Adam to A Primitive mind where all
the men are working as laborers
according to the queen men are either
used as slaves for sacrifices or
occasionally used to procreate the site
disgusts at him but when he tries to
speak out his thoughts he is beaten up
and taken away unfortunately while the
guards are escorting him back to the
Queen's residence they are attacked by
Roxanne's gang the notorious cult
members slay all of the Queen's guards
and apprehend Adam sadly among the
casualties is also Dove as she breathes
her last her brother will arrives to
help her but it is too late meanwhile
Adam is brought to Texans Chambers where
the serpent Queen asks him to join their
cause she even kisses him passionately
to seduce him into their team however
Adam being the wise guy that he is
refuses straight away I'm an astronaut
lady not a simp this causes an
altercation between the two but before
Adam can get hurt the queen Jake and
will disguised as guards come to his
rescue tax and tries to fight back but
the queen knocks her out with a single
punch before leaving on their way out
through the tunnels the astronauts
discussed the state of the planet and
Jake reveals that they have less time
than he had guessed earlier according to
his recent calculations antarius May
blow up in a matter of days the queen
overhears their conversation and brings
out her locket which has a special kind
of element in it it turns out that the
element is extracted from a place called
the burn Zone which is the same spot
that the spaceship from Earth landed one
thousand years ago hearing this the
astronauts get excited because if they
can somehow reach the place and restart
the ship they can head back to Earth the
queen also agrees to help them and
together they start marching towards the
burn Zone along the way they evade
several of Texans goons and also managed
to free some men who were locked up as
slaves once they finally reach outside
Queen sumeru tells the astronauts that
they still have to travel several
kilometers as the burn zone is located
behind a large Hill despite the
challenges and the serpent group hot on
their tails Jake and Adam decide to
continue their Journey shortly after
Adam tries convincing the queen to come
along with them mentioning that it's
much safer up there on Earth however she
politely declines asserting that she
doesn't rule the people but serves them
which I guess means that she should let
them all die just then a massive
earthquake hits which causes the group
to Tumble down with this Jake deduces
that the planet's impending doom is
nearing after a while the group group
comes across the skeletal remains of a
man and when Jake examines it he learns
that the man died some 900 years ago the
same year that humans came to Antares on
further inspection he also finds out
that there was a solar blast in the area
and that is why most of the men perished
hearing this the queen realizes that it
was the same flash of light that their
ancestors witnessed centuries ago since
the light was caused by natural causes
the men were innocent after all hence
all these years their religion which
stated that men are dangerous and evil
was built upon a lie the Revelation
devastates the queen but the boys tell
her to keep moving as they don't have
much time left in the next scene the
group finally arrives outside the burn
Zone which appears to be a huge space
Dome Jake and little will try to restart
the engine from the control room while
Adam and the queen head to another room
to engineer the controls from there
after a lot of struggle the astronauts
managed to reignite the engine but
unfortunately paxan and her goons also
show up a deadly battle ensues between
the two parties but Adam with the
high-end gadgets manages to blow up most
of the evil women now only taxan is
remaining but she challenges the queen
to a fair one-on-one combat to which the
latter agrees at first the two are
equally matched but soon using her
impressive combat techniques the queen
gains the upper hand realizing that she
is about to lose the evil taxin takes
out her knife and lunges forward to
attack but once again the queen easily
counters after beating up the serpent
Queen for a while the queen throws her
against a generator electrocuting her to
a pulp still the resilient accent is
unwilling to give up and she charges at
the queen with her knife but this time
Adam Fires at her and finishes her once
and for all at the end of the day men
and guns have their way hell yeah Amen
brother back in the control room Jake
has managed to start the spaceship and
it is now ready for takeoff after
learning that men are not responsible
for any of the atrocities on Antares and
that the planet is dying the queen also
decides to join Jake Adam and will in
their journey to to the Earth soon the
spaceship takes off and flies into the
air all the people of Antares the men
the Queen's soldiers and even tax and
cult members gaze at the large spaceship
in awe seeing them without their leader
Adam feels bad and suggests that they
bring everyone inside the ship as it has
enough space for 500 people Jake tries
to assert that the violent earthquakes
can destroy the ship but Adam and the
queen are willing to take their chances
left with no choice Jake obliges to the
orders and starts descending the
spaceship soon they arrive on the
surface and the people are awestruck to
witness the large structure which they
previously called the burn Zone the
queen sumeru steps out and orders
everyone to get inside mentioning that
their planet is about to die so that
they are venturing into a far away
planet the planet will have several
other people where there is no disparity
in gender of race or religion oh I guess
they're not talking about Earth after
all hearing this the people become
excited and they immediately enter the
ship however before Jake and Adam can
pilot the spaceship away from the
planets a massive earthquake rocks
everyone when they look outside they
notice the giant serpent attacking one
of the ship's propellers with time
running out Adam orders Jake to apply
Full Throttle on the propeller
unfortunately as soon as he does so the
serpent backs off because of the Fire
released from the propeller with this
the spaceship finally takes off and
leaves planet and Terrace forever in the
final scene a woman enters the control
room and Hans little will is a lost dog
apparently the dog was saved by the
woman who also hid it from taxan the
movie ends as everyone inside the
control room plays with the puppy while
the spaceship blasts off to Earth
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching